in the last video we were able to come
up with a an expression which is
essentially our area as a our combined
area of both the equilateral triangle
and our square as a function of where we
make the cut as a function of x and so
now we're ready to optimize to figure
out the x that gives us the minimum
combined area of these two things
so let's figure out where we might have
a minimum point and to figure out the
candidate minimum points we have to find
the critical points and to find the
critical points we have to figure out
where the derivative of our function
where the derivative of our function
might be equal to zero or might be
undefined so let's take the derivative
here the derivative let's see the power
rule it's going to be two times all of
this business times x
so it's going to be 2 times this which
is going to be square root of 3
over 9 plus 1 over 8
times x
minus 25 over 2 which i can just write
as 12.5 minus 12.5 is the derivative now
this is going to be defined for any x so
let's think about when it might be equal
to 0 to find the critical points so
let's think about and i will do this in
yellow when does square root of 3 over 9
plus 1 8
times
x
minus 12.5 equals zero well you could
add 12.5 to both sides and you get
square root of 3 over 9 plus 1 8
times x is equal to 12.5
divide both sides by all of this
hairiness and you get x is equal to
12.5
over
square root of 3
over 9 plus 1 over 8 and i will use a
calculator to figure out what this is
roughly equal to
so let's turn on our calculator and we
get 12.5
divided by
divided by
the square root of 3
divided by 9
plus
plus
1 divided by 8 the order of operations
should make everything work out right
over here and then oh i wrote 11.5
that's not that's no good
so let me
make this a 12.5
let's see so i have 12.5 divided by
square root of 3 over 9 plus 1 8. now i
just have to put the closing parentheses
closing parentheses
and i get
39.38 so this is approximately equal to
approximately equal to 39.33
now we don't know if this is a minimum
point or a maximum point we could try to
test it out etcetera etcetera we could
graph it but the easiest way to do it
analytically is to just do the second
derivative test is our function concave
upward or concave downwards or neither
at this point right over here so let's
take our second derivative let's take
our second derivative so the second
derivative which i will do in blue
the second derivative of our area as a
function of x is just going to be equal
to
is just going to be equal to this stuff
square root of 3 over 9 plus
1 8. so our second derivative for any x
the second derivative this is just zero
so the second derivative for any x is
going to be positive
so this is always going to be greater
than zero so for any x for any x that
we're dealing with we have a positive
second derivative so it's concave
upwards
concave
upwards
concave upwards so our function looks
like this
our function looks something like this
so if we found the x value where our
slope is zero where our derivative is
zero we indeed found an x value at which
our function takes on a minimum
a minimum point this is a minimum point
so there you have it we have answered
the question where do we make the cut we
make the cut at x is equal to
at x is equal to 39.3
39.38
and so this length will be 39.38 for our
triangle and then the length for our
square is going to be 100
minus that and if you wanted to figure
out what that minimum combined area is
you could just substitute back into this
hairy expression